it's been the privilege the presumption
of intellectuals to say as a new social
innovation rides into town suffer this
and the thing comes undone you watch
that happen now for 300 years as the
innovations come you know and accumulate
the sky never falls hi I'm Nicholas tree
with reason TV and today we're talking
with grant McCracken who is a research
affiliate at MIT x' culture convergence
consortium okay thanks grant you're also
the author of a number of books we're
gonna discuss let's start with your
latest chief culture officer what's its
premise and why is it important for
people to know about it the premise is
that the corporate world is getting
better
responding to the sheer dynamism of the
competitive marketplace but it
systematically ignores the cultural
content the the cultural developments
that shape consumer taste and preference
so in the book one of the examples you
use was Motorola's razor phone sure
Jeffrey frost was a guy who had worked
for Nike and a couple of other companies
and it came to Motorola and discovered
that it was a corporation that practiced
death by committee
stalling good ideas in the innovation
process and he knew especially that they
had a ten-year when it came to culture
so when he saw this handset come out of
the lab he thought oh two things first
of all this can work in our contemporary
culture but he also knew that he had to
keep it away from the inclination of the
corporation to kill things in committee
so he sort of snuck it through the cover
of darkness brought it to marketplace so
he's a kind of naturally occurring CCO
you call for the creation of the chief
culture officer and in corporations or
in businesses that are selling stuff
what would a chief culture officer do I
think they would have the daunting task
of keeping track of everything that's
happening in the one example I use in
the book is Alice Waters creating Chez
Panisse in 1973 at some point you want
to have a CCO in place who can say you
know this tiny little innovation that
took place in cooks Ville California is
actually rushing towards the
mainstream and you want to pick that up
as soon as possible talk about the book
that you're finishing up soon
tentatively titled are fully titled cul
traumatic what is it about and how does
it fit into your your unfolding work the
book runs on two rails one is how the
corporation creates innovation that you
know is a hot topic the other is how do
individuals with their own lives engage
in experiments that help shape and
define who they are so what's an example
of a cult romantic reality TV this is
the true story their time when MTV was
no longer able to rely on rock or music
videos it needed another cheap of source
of programming and someone said well
what if we all these cult romantics
begin with this little what-if and in
this case it was well what if we just
stuck some people in a house and we had
you know high-end cameras and the sound
won't be very good but this could be
interesting it really fought I think the
instincts of everybody who had made
television up to that date in which
model you spend two million dollars to
make a pilot which goes more often
doesn't go and this is a cheap and
cheerful model how do you respond to
critics we were just like well look at
reality TV this is at the basement of
everything that is good and normal of
mom's Chevrolet and apple pie I think
what they're missing is the sky is not
falling in it hasn't ever fallen and
it's been the privilege the presumption
of intellectuals to say as a new social
innovation rides into town giving the
vote to women or giving property rights
to you know in the sixteenth century or
something right whatever it is some
social innovation you can depend upon
intellectuals to get on their high horse
and say suffer this and the thing comes
undone you give the vote to women and
you can just say goodbye to a stable
society we've watched that happen now
for 300 years as the innovations come
you know and accumulate the sky never
falls simply did give the women the vote
and now we have reality TV your work
which I've been following at least since
plenitude which was an online book
published in the 90s and talked about
the quickening speciation of social
types in North America and Western
Europe what's the consistency or the
through line in the work
you've been doing right I guess the big
transit anthropologist is a classical
anthropologist and at some point in my
career I thought I would begin to study
contemporary culture contemporary
American culture the big challenge there
is that it doesn't look like almost
anything we've ever seen in the
traditional ethnographic handbook so the
question is well what's here that
shouldn't be here strictly speaking and
how do you account for it and what was
happening in in the 90s was this
fantastic speciation and this is that
suddenly I mean yeah I remember in a
plenitude you talked about the tour that
you took of a Toronto mall with a
teenager and where when you were growing
up there were essentially three role
models for four boys I mean you could be
what a hood and nerd or a geek or center
or a jock and what did you find in the
Toronto mall there were something like
twelve species of and that's changed in
a very interesting way so kids use stuff
to make almost kind of a lifelong
commitment to one group or another and
then they began to mix and match them
and now they're kind of modular now
their stylistic signatures more than
anything they are anything why are
people reluctant to embrace that there's
a notion that says if I admit to the
choices other people have made as they
construct their lives I some as and when
those depart from my own I'm somehow
repudiating my own choices and in a
world of plenitude
there's no repudiation there are
politics either explicit or embedded in
your work well to the extent that it
stems from cultural motives and to the
extent that it manifests itself for me
at least as an anthropologist in a
cultural frame I can talk about it
without talking about politics but if I
extrapolate if I make political
assumptions I think the chief one is
Gees good you know structurally stable
things happen when existing institutions
forgo their claim to decide who should
say what about whom in what contexts
when you accept that change is the only
constant ironically you get a more
stable social structure comment I mean
that's the big anthropological question
is is there remember when people read
software they would talk about criminals
the smallest instruction set you could
actually establish in order to get the
maximum amount of of code and and it
that's that's the open question what is
the kernel what is the the minimum
instruction set and and maybe there's a
point at which we embrace certain kinds
of innovation that that really over that
explode that and then we're in for it
but but we keep thinking that's our
reform ever I'm just speaking down
perhaps Canadian but I mean that's our
reflex that the things going to come
undone it just doesn't well I want to
thank grant McCracken author of
plenitude chief culture officer and
forthcoming cul traumatic for talking
with reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you